so today we're gonna take a look at the
French winner and this has been
requested by several people so I've been
wanting to do this for a while so I know
I knew I was gonna be doing this one and
I really tried to make this you know one
lecture just a one-hour video but just
couldn't do it it's too hard so we're
doing let's say two parts that's the
goal
you never know because it's sometimes it
ends up being three four five parts you
know I just I can't help myself I you
know I try to go in depth and really
cover all of the lines really well so we
will even be skipping several side lines
today but I do want to try to do this as
succinctly as possible so let's say two
lectures on the winner and the winner
occurs after the moves
efore ecigs french defense d4 d5 and as
lulu ojek has taught us black strikes at
the center like a bolt of lightning
hopefully you guys have all watched the
learning about it with lulu series
because she comes up with lots of good
metaphors and in this position the most
classical response the most common way
to protect the e-pawn is Knight to c3
and instead of playing a move like
Knight to f6 or the Rubenstein Bishop to
b4 and we have the winter wear and
especially when it first sort of came
into fashion it was not to be sort of a
dubious opening it is sort of a an
interesting approach to the position and
it normally leads to sort of sharp
fighting chess especially if both
players are in the mood white can play
some really aggressive stuff and get
positions that really encouraged a lot
of attacking chests and very interesting
fighting games but you know you are
committing sort of your dark squared
bishop which is an important defender
very often in the French is it kind of
guy that normally you keep them a little
bit closer to the Kings side for defense
so is giving away the dark squares
because at some point you know White's
going to play here and ask you to take
the knight will that come back
to haunt you will white get sort of an
attack on the dark squares or will the
fact that you intend to [ __ ] White's
pawn structure mean blacks going to get
a lot of play on the queenside so
already you're going to get sort of an
imbalanced game right from the start
and in a minute we'll go over the the
main line which is the advanced
variation and we're going to slowly work
our way towards the poisoned pawn
variation which will have to wait a week
so next week if I know some people were
specifically requesting the poisoned
pawn variation so I do want to get there
and that'll that'll get a full hour of
attention but I do want to cover a
couple of the side lines now if this
were another three four five part series
complete winter where I'd cover all the
side lines and there's so many here you
know you can go like here and here and
here I mean there's so many moves that
that you can play you can take this but
okay just for the sake of time we're
only going to cover one of these tonight
and there's this very interesting gambit
and this is the most popular side line
in this position and we'll we'll come
back and we'll play e5 here in just a
minute and it is it's a it's a gambit so
you're offering this pawn which is the
critical test and the point of the move
is now White's next move is a three and
when you take I can take back with a
knight and I don't have to ruin my pawn
structure so and you can also argue as
black you don't have to accept you could
just play some developing move you can
even play Knight to c6 but Knight to f6
is a most common way to decline this
gambit you can just argue okay this guy
not well placed on e to and you can just
sort of play off of that fact
however the critical test is what we're
going to look at we take on e4 and okay
I guess after a three you're you're
asked the question obviously you can go
back if you wish but then he gets to
take on e4 so more critical is taking
and after the recapture for the moment
black is up upon so I guess I'd also
like to get to class involved early
in this position I'm just wondering
whether what the class is thinking about
what you guys would play in this
position because there's a couple
different approaches you could choose 96
yeah I said yeah the window we're expert
in the back
nose nose the main line so we'll
definitely come back to this this is the
the main move just putting pressure on D
for anybody else want to play anything
else okay excellent so let's take a look
at those I guess let's just start here
if Knight to f6
okay protecting your pawn that seems
very logical white should and you know
try to get at that pawn again by pinning
the night and now you're threatening to
take on e4 and all of the highest-rated
games in this variation have gone as
follows h6 and after this capture white
gets to take here and instead of going
all the way back to d8 you can go to e7
and you get you know a normal French
like position seems like something that
could have come out of the Rubinstein
where black can maneuver his Knight or
you can just put the night on d7 and
play c5 if you get those sort of ideas
so for people that are a fan of those
types of positions you can play this way
but your interesting is f5 which I don't
think is a particularly good move it
feels a little bit dubious to give away
your dark squared Bishop and then put
all of your pawns on like squares so
there's you know a lot of a lot of dark
squares in this this area that could
potentially be very weak and white
actually gets plenty of compensation for
the pawn in this position after I move
f3
so okay you take take and what would you
guys like to play here now we'll see how
greedy people are alright so you can
grab the pawn and your computer will
tell you for a little while that this is
okay and then eventually it'll tell you
it's not okay so here there's actually a
couple things that have been tried and
this position has never really occurred
at the high level so there's not a large
sample size of good players that have
tested this position because it's just
not very very good for black because
after here black in this position it's
occurred eight times in my database and
blacks made the same blunder and lost
the same way in all the games so I don't
know the you know Queen to g3 is the
best move but it has a hundred percent
success rate so I recommend it because
everybody has invariably played the move
c6 you attack the C pawn I'm all about
holding on to my pawns I protect my pawn
but this actually is already losing
though it does take comodo like ten
seconds to find it so I'll give you guys
you know eleven seconds but I think here
you guys will be able to find this
there's a little combination the next
couple of moves there's some only moves
but I think it will be easy enough that
we should be able to solve it in this
room so if you guys were white what
would you guys play here Bishop f4 with
two threats you're going to take the
knight and you're going to go here and
you're going to take on g7 so okay yeah
ninety-seven okay I protect my knight I
protected e5
all right everything's great I'm up two
pawns but now what does white have
rook d1 yeah
in the follow-up
kind of want to take the night there's a
lot of moves that are good
yeah but taking the night is the most
crushing the point is is Bishop e5 and
you're going to take on g7 alright I got
I got one more one more trick here okay
you take check all right so my last my
last trick you can still mess up the
night blocks yeah which is much better
here like this pin you know can actually
be annoying but when the night goes back
I mean you're just you're losing this
and alright bucks just down a piece okay
and then white wins and this has
occurred in like every game that's ever
played this position so but to summarize
yeah you don't you don't want to take
that pawn slightly better is just
ignoring for the moment and after some
some normal moves you get a position
like this and you are up upon but white
has a very easy way to develop and he's
just bringing his his pieces into the
game black is going to hope to you know
set up his pieces like this to try to
neutralize any attack that white might
generate but we'll go ahead and we'll
look at a game that started from this
basic position this is sort of you know
how they how they generally play up and
we'll look at a game between dos and
nickel ik from 2015 and will notice a
2600 player here with the black pieces
actually got into trouble immediately
against a player rated 24 50 so this is
a very dangerous way to play as black I
suspect that the higher rated player as
black here was thinking well I need to
play something that's sort of crazy
because I need to win the game you know
he's 150 points lower either than me so
I'll play this and it'll be crazy and
then maybe all I'll get some chances but
I mean white just played really well and
the game wasn't even very long so after
the move a 5 white took here which is ok
you didn't have to do that certainly but
uh black already made a mistake there's
a right way in a wrong way to take back
the bishop and he chose the wrong way
so very early on already there was a bit
of a mistake here by black so how would
you guys capture the pomp of the bishop
okay you're gonna take what the e pawn
because you've always had problems yeah
exactly yeah so this was the right way
to take back as Darian said be at b5
before this sort of attacking thing you
want to do and you do want to deny the
knight this square
I suppose what he probably was thinking
was well White has the e-file I mean so
if we if you take this way White's going
to get to double on the e-file and
that's that's true it maybe he was
thinking oh if I take this way which is
what he played perhaps I'll be able to
go here you know maybe I'll get to use
the open file but it's just not true
after this move it's just not true
you'll never get you know you look there
because white immediately just gets to
make too many threats and the immediate
threat is to go here attacking this in
this so something has to be done about
that so Knight h6 and it's kind of funny
what white did to its it's not good but
its position so good you can sort of
make a little mistake here he went here
text text abrooke gives it a little poke
which is okay it's an okay move and
after here he should just go to e5 you
know this is that's just a great
diagonal for the bishop and as in the
game you can still put your knight here
if that's what you you want to do but he
went all the way back so I mean there's
just a waste of time it's like but I
suppose I should so good he's still
better after giving black two more moves
for free I don't know maybe he was
expecting we got fade and like how how
you're worse don't you want to draw with
me but okay so he goes here tax the
night the night jumps in you know so is
the night going to end up getting
trapped there or is it going to be a
really powerful piece the b7 pawn is is
attacked so it's defended and yeah
what's to become of that Knight is easy
a nuisance or is he going to get trapped
in there is eventually going to be able
to go pick them
up or or what and here already why can
consider playing a move like g4 and just
getting an attack and if black takes on
g4 you take back with the Queen and and
you have a very promising attack though
it seems kind of strange normally you
might want to get your rooks over there
first or do something else he played a
little bit slower but a very good move
h4 here comes h5 h6 and black is nowhere
near attacking white so I mean White's
just going to be first here in the race
to attack each other okay all right so
is the knight like trapped in there nope
so yeah Queen g3 very nice move just
defending the knight again so you're not
letting him take h6 which gets them into
a little bit of trouble later but I mean
maybe it's okay but the big problem is
now white just brings his rooks into the
attack he will be able to use the g6
square in the future and maybe can get a
rook there so he needs to do sort of a
rook lift and we're going to sort of
speed through it because it's I just
kind of want to demonstrate how much fun
white is having in this position and
it's so bad the computer wants you to
play f4 and then it white doesn't take
the rook he played Victor some funny
move like this and then you take the
room you know there's some sort of like
funny business but that's just how bad
it is because here the position is
actually already lost so both
strategically and just tactically the
computer already announces that it's
it's winning so we had some threats on
g7 and okay and the pressure just builds
and builds and then there's so many
sacrifices and okay in the game he
played Queen f4 which is a good move but
he missed like an amazing brilliant
tactic here so you may want to pause
your videos at home this is you know a
super tactical challenge I don't think
this is a very easy move to find so I
think there's a very but it's it's very
spectacular so I do like to just pause
for a second give you guys a chance and
I suppose I can give you one hint what
you would really love to do here is why
is play queen here check because the
King would have to drop back and do to
the pin
you could play here mate yeah a Knight
takes pawn Knight takes f5 is just a
crusher and if you take this you got to
get the rook out of the way take the
bishop and you can't even take the rook
back yeah because if you go here it's
this this checkmate you go here there's
a pin so the game would be over okay and
I position this winning you don't have
to find the the knockout blow to win so
instead Queen to f4 was played and now
yeah he just brings all of the pieces in
you know he's getting ready to take on
g7 with something he's going to take
with a bishop you know if he takes here
then you're threatening to take here
there's all sorts of threats also you're
you just you're losing upon but more
importantly in this position after here
your Queen can no longer defend these
scores that it needs to so black gave it
up and I just wanted to show that as a
powerful example of how quickly things
can go wrong and the type of initiative
that white can get when you do play this
this variation and will so will go all
the way back and we'll look at the the
mainline here in this variation which is
Knight to c6
so we're attacking the d4 pawn so
typically they pin the knight
it's kind of funny because that's what
we were doing to them and then they put
a knight here so they could go here so
what do we do we do the same thing and
now we're going to play a six and when
they take the knight we're going to take
back with a knight and not ruin our pawn
structure and there's actually several
moves here and this has actually been
covered on our youtube channel before so
for the move castling I recommend the
video that vara Cobian already did here
this is his game mark Ginsberg versus a
cobia in 2015 u.s. chess league so he
did a video on this which is which is
excellent so you may want to check that
out
but also you may be surprised to learn
that taking is not a very popular move I
suspect it may be a lot of people just
okay that's the point you know you take
back the black actually gets an okay
position here after what move I guess
I'll ask the audience here what's the
move that makes most people not want to
play this variation yeah
Queen d5 and I mean this is this is
certainly playable for white but the
point is okay double attack after you
protect everything you're playing the
move f5 which you retain upon but you
know ice I just kind of suspect that
again White has a really good initiative
in such a position where you've done
sort of the same thing with your your
pawns here and White has the simple plan
of you know developing and castling
queenside so I mean I think this is a
perfectly respectable way to play as
white you should understand that this is
the position you're going to get but
okay there's ever leagues anything wrong
with it it's just not very popular
because some people don't like to be
down upon even though most people do
when they play this variation there very
often trying to to play a gambit the
main move is Bishop to g5 which will
often transpose I mean you also could
have played Bishop to e3 first but it'll
often transpose you're just provoking f6
before you go to e3 so in any lines
where black plays f5 it'll just be a
transposition so you're just hoping f6
is a little bit loosening in certain
variations and we get a position like
this and okay we we're up upon and just
to take the main line here a little bit
further you know we get we get to do the
same thing to them and the same way they
get counter play is with a move like f3
so take it the open G file and after a
move like this the position is is
actually completely equal the computers
will tell you zero point zero zero you
are up upon as black but white has a lot
of good piece play and the potential to
use the g5
well your night can go back or it can go
to a five this is sort of the position
that you can expect so you know if you
like being up a pond
you know you want to be black here if
you sort of like the initiative that you
might be able to get with the white
pieces then you want apply white here
but it should be equal so that I'll do
it for our coverage of that variation so
we'll step back to this position and
we'll get serious 'if I've it will only
look at at one move for black here which
is c5 the typical break that you want to
play you want to attack the center when
you're playing the French the two ways
to do it RC 5 and f 6 here you want to
play C 5 and you know you're going to
continue to put pressure on the center
ok and the main move is a 3 and again
there's several sidelines we'll look at
just one more because I was playing the
winner for a little bit but I didn't
like it mostly because there's a lot of
variations like this and if you end up
playing lower rated players a lot it is
kind of annoying when they play a move
like Bishop to d2 not because it's a
good move or anything but it's just
because the positions actually are very
draw after this continuation so it's
these types of things that made me not
actually want to play this as black but
you can have a look for yourself and
we'll see how you guys feel about it in
the main point is not only well you're
not going to damage my pawn structure
because I'll just take back with the
bishop but weight is also thinking about
Knight to be 5 this is sort of the main
point and then ok maybe we can jump into
these dark squares you know if you have
to trade the bishop and then I jump in
to d6 ok I'm feeling feeling pretty good
so I mean yeah so if you take on d4 then
Knight to b5 which isn't it's an OK
variation but uh mostly they develop
their pieces so that when you ever you
put a knight here I'll be in time to
castle and there's there's two moves
Knight to b5 being the main line but
there's also this move of a3 which leads
to some interesting positions
so they take obviously we're not taking
with a pond that's why we put our Bishop
here and we develop our knight and if
they take here we can easily push and
take the e pond so that's not really a
threat so both people get on with
developing and now black takes and so
now White has to make a decision
so both recaptures on d4 are possible
and playable I wonder what the audience
would play here you're going to lose the
pond and what's funny is this is at
least the next couple of moves are a
little bit more complicated because it
doesn't look like yeah you're just
losing the pond right but it's a lot
more complicated than that you know
because there's a there's a bishop here
and even though this is less popular
this variation it's like the universal
choice of the higher rated players yeah
and I think white does just get a small
advantage nothing too major after this
move here okay so it's a discover an
attack on the night so when you take
back we take the night and you just get
some position like this where White has
the two bishops black has an isolated
deep on but again it should be
relatively even so you can play this way
and I think I think this is a good way
for what to play just if you just want a
very small advantage with white I think
I think this is decent but it isn't
anything too special so it's great for
white does it what if you want join not
fritz thanks 0.00
yes Prince though but uh but yeah I'm
it's nothing too major I think you know
blacks next move is probably like Queen
f6 get a little bit pressure okay I mean
it's it's fine you think white is like a
lot better that's kind of what my
initial impression was but I am just
playing around with it a little bit it
doesn't it is easier to play white
definitely yes that's why I think this
is a good practical choice for for
people playing white to play this
variation
mm-hmm
but more common is taking with the
bishop which keeps the center intact
Knight a5 c3 and I do want to show a
game only because mostly it's the kind
of Queen side play that black is looking
for not just in the window wear but in
the French in general so I think it's an
instructive for for that reason this is
the game between Jordi alza balusters
who's rated 2200 versus Andres Rodriguez
Villa who's 2500 so obviously the 2,500
player got all the play he wanted on the
Queen side and what we never got any
real chances here so in this position
rook c8 is possible but in the game a 5
and we'll see the typical play that
black wants to achieve on the Queen side
so after castles he took an blacks plan
is to lock down the Queen side you know
he's thinking about King bring the Queen
in to look at some of these light
squares the knight comes in looking at
some of these squares maybe we trade the
bishops let's draw as many arrows as we
can we can we bring our rooks here these
are the sorts of things that black is
going to do on the Queen side because
obviously when they play at a3 they have
a few weaknesses over there that black
is going to go try to exploit
immediately and white should for his
part you know get something going over
here on the Kings side that's where he
has more space his pawns are pointing
that way but it just never happened in
this game so again well it's not our
featured game so we'll go relatively
quickly through it ok this didn't really
achieve as much as I'm assuming he had
hoped it would and so here we see it and
he's trying to get rid of this bishop
obviously in the French that's your
trouble Bishop if you can trade it then
yeah you're doing pretty good especially
as this guy is is usually a pretty good
attacker for white so white prevented
that idea with Queen - II - ok very
sensible and now black just gets display
over here the Knights going maybe to c4
maybe to b3
okay he does something over there he
just keeps his Bishop nice and safe
and the night jumps end okay and it's
very interesting what happened here - he
just calmly brings all of his pieces
over to the queenside and I like this
this move here - he just tucks it away
so the bishop is protected just in case
you ever need to you know move that
night just in case you ever need the
Queen to retreat and what just has
nothing so I think he's hoping that
there's you know some sort of sacrifice
like I'm putting this here and something
is taking but uh it just doesn't work so
here actually Black is just winning
Queen f3 is the mistake that lost the
game and we'll just go quickly through
it you can pause if you want to solve it
I don't know if this was a blitz game
but there was some like very suspicious
stuff from both sides here I just wanted
to point out the kind of stuff that
blacks should aim for on the Queen side
with this game he took here which is
just winning and there's no sacrifices
like if you take here we can just like
take this if this thing takes then you
take here with check so there's just no
sacrifices that are working he went here
which is also double question mark so he
took this and then you went here or also
double question mark but then very
strange like this one I don't know if
it's a transmission error or there's a
blitz game or whatever but I mean black
one here instead of you know playing the
obvious move yeah so that's why I'm not
that's why we're not focusing on this
game you know and then they okay took
that and then some stuff happened and
then resigns so I don't actually know
what really happened there I suspect
there was something something fishy but
uh but it's just an example of how you
should play on the queenside in certain
positions just in the French at large
then I just wanted to point out okay and
we will return to this position with
Bishop to d2 and we'll look at the main
move here which is Knight to b5
if you do nothing I play Knight to d6
and you will be able to castle so you
take ng castle then again there's two
moves that white can play f4 is the main
move will actually see a game in a in a
different line we'll look at this move
in just a second which is also you know
it's I've seen a lot of the higher rated
players seem to play here so it's always
important when you're looking in a
database not just to look for the most
common moves but also what are the
highest rated players playing in those
positions but the main move is here and
after a six you you know come on in and
you're hoping to undermine the center
and undermine this Knight by taking in
the center moves like f6 sometimes if
this knights here you can take here you
know to eliminate the defender of the
night these sorts of things are all a
part of blacks plan so you take and very
often they just ignore this pawn they
leave it here you can just play around
it and f6 so you get a position sort of
like this and what's sort of amazing is
the move that I think a lot of people
would play here is is wrong so I saw
I'll test the class the class again in
this position what would you guys play
here as black mm-hmm that's the question
yeah 1975 right because it's the obvious
move yeah so something is wrong with
this you know it looks great you know
okay you're going to take back I'm going
to get to grab your knight how fantastic
you know but you they take and they
bring the rather rook into the game this
sort of dangerous and now there's
actually already a winning tactic it's
not super easy to see I think maybe some
people will be able to find it but a
what would you guys play here is white
bishop x pawn okay King takes
the rook lift does win as well but even
more crushing and to the point is Queen
to g5 and you have this sort of idea
you're going to check they're going to
go back you're going to check they're
going to go back you bring the rope in
so for example just some casual move
check check and the rook comes over and
this rook lifts will conclude the affair
there's just nothing that you can do
anymore is black so you do have to be
careful there's a lot of these lines
that you know do deserve some some
accuracy so the main move here actually
is to take the knight and then after
they take back now you can take on e5
and it's still really really complicated
because now they have this move which
you know has a has some some potential
for danger but ok take care and you'll
get a position like this and it should
be equal I don't know who's more scared
it's white scared is black scared who
knows it looks kind of dangerous for
both sides so there there's you know
some some danger for both players but
objectively this should be equal so this
is one way to play but I want to come
all the way back one more time to this
variation and look at the move D takes
c5 and now we'll look at a game between
much higher rated players that we've
seen so far the game between Londa and
Knight H so a 2650 player versus a 2700
player so ok very respectable players
and the game is actually very short in
this position black attacked both of the
pawns and white played and unusual but
not unknown move Knight to f3 Queen to
c3 protecting both pawns is more common
but now after here
you get to go here and you'll you'll
take one of the ponds so this is sort of
the main line and you know you get
counter play by playing f6 and trying to
undermine the night as per usual in this
game
however Knight f3 was played which just
allows black to take he's hoping to make
use of the d4 square so very often in
lines in the French where they end up
taking here they're trying to get the d4
square for their night so you just place
here Queen to b6 you know you always
have to be careful there's definitely no
great gifts here with where the Queen is
and you know something you want to be I
watch for but there's definitely nothing
there and so after here he takes the
bishop and I don't know it feels like
Black has already emerged with a
slightly better position and here
after this move if the knight has to
retreat and it does then you're probably
doing pretty well as black because if if
they go here well you can immediately
undermine or you can play Queen to g6 so
in the game he just went back and
there's there's a blunder coming up
which is why it's kind of a show this
game okay we want to infiltrate on the
light squares on the Queen side so here
comes the rook and we'll get to the
action that's what that's what the
people want
so after here black played this move
which very sneakily prevents what
White's next move was but why played it
anyway so I guess he already missed the
threat so here white it's white to move
in blunder what's what's the obvious
move why did you put your knight there
Knight f4
mmm yes so I assume that's what he was
thinking is like okay you went here just
to prevent me from putting my knight
there but it also very sneakily defends
against what I assume is just sort of a
natural looking move I mean
all right that's why I was maneuvering
my knight I mean I was going to d4 and I
can take where take on e5 okay but this
is wrong
yeah yeah that's the point so this
actually doesn't work yeah if you take
you take here you're on the Queen no
this didn't happen instead black played
better
let's keep analyzing this for hours and
take care and woop da take care of it
but this actually would be a mistake so
I assume white had figured that out he's
like okay I got a little trick but the
joke's on white because black hasn't
even better move okay
Knight f4
yeah exactly
okay right yeah it's so yeah as pointed
out the point is let's listen sorry this
was passed so he takes here and the
point is yeah if you if you take with
anything let's take with this as pointed
out Queen takes is the whole point but I
got a surprise for you
g3o what you can do about that
hey yeah what you want by working for
okay I take yeah and that's the
important element that perhaps was was
missed here yeah if you take care you
lose your night but if you check you
don't
so here the game ended you're in check
you move the King and I take your queen
and and I'm winning so you know a
display of just completely just mantling
a very strong player with some some
early tactics so so yeah it does yeah I
mean it's there's there's a couple
little tricks there so a very excellent
game now will get really really really
serious we'll go back to this position
and we'll play the main move a three and
you you basically have to take it's not
completely obligatory but he does have a
similar idea white does if you play this
way
and then if we can break the pin we know
we'd have these sorts of ideas so the
major move for white in this position is
b4 and you can take either way White's
idea is the same so you've temporarily
broken the pin so the knight jumps in
and here he goes and you might be
thinking alright I just take check you
know feeling feeling pretty good but
this is not a very good version because
here comes this this Bishop who's going
to be rather annoying so after you
go back because otherwise I'm playing 96
I'm taking this and I mean okay after
after this I'm just crushing you that's
not a movie you want to see I guess you
have to play Bishop b6 but this is very
good for white so much better in this
position is actually to take on d4 and
this actually has been played by a
couple super grandmasters Gris Chuck I
can't think of the other one but there
was somebody else that that has played
this so I mean it is playable but it's
the same reply here for white I'm going
to d6 so we'd better stop me
and now f4 and we're going to you this
night we'll be able to go here or we can
decide if we just want to play around
the pond at some point we're going to
get your Bishop which will be a nice
success so play you know we'll be sort
of in White's favor I think this is the
sort of thing that white player is you
know really prefer to play but it has
been played by good people so you can
you can play that way but I mean okay
almost anybody everybody in this
position does end up taking the night so
you have given away your dark squared
Bishop which can be kind of scary if you
ever end up castling
you know sometimes that becomes one of
your best defenders but you do have some
some counter play on the Queen side so
it's a very nice imbalance game and I
guess we'll just look at the main move
here for for black which is Knight to e7
I can't go to have six so this is the
next most logical square and next week
we'll look at the the alternatives here
to the main line which is Queen to g4
there's also the moves Knight to f3
which just seems like a normal move even
though it's not supposed to be as
theoretically challenging and we'll look
at h4 which is not very popular but it
is quite dangerous so we'll we'll take a
look at those moves but we got to get
serious here tonight so Queen to g4 and
our main line for next week is going to
be the poisoned pawn variation so like
Queen to c7 which is
obviously upon sacrifice so this is this
will be the starting position for next
week so people can start preparing for
the first round the next Monday night
mayhem but I do want to point out this
other very popular variation which is
just a castle okay that that's one way
to defend your Jeep on and in order to
give you the false impression that this
is unplayable for black we'll switch the
colors and show you a game that white
one because that's what's important you
want to think that you can't play this
way and will even go back all the way to
the start so that we can we can watch it
again from a different perspective and
we'll show a game that was just played
two months ago here in the US Chess
Championship does anybody know a game
I'm talking about nope
okay castles and there was the the game
between Cara Juana as white playing Sam
Shanklin and Sam actually just finished
up a tournament in a Edmonton just now
and now me got eight out of nine points
so he did I he did very well so Sam I
mean he's not too shabby but you know
Cara Juana's Cara Juana so he was able
to win this game
and it might not look like white has
that tremendous of an attack you know
you got your queen out there big deal
but you can get some play really quickly
with moves like Bishop d3 the bishop
sometimes can go here you know this
Knight can come in and jump around we
actually can get quite a big attack so
playing this way is actually quite
dangerous as black in it in a way is
playing right into what white wants
white is is playing for an attack on the
king meanwhile you get some sort of play
on the Queen side but uh you know I'm
just trying to checkmate you so the main
move here is Bishop d3
and I do want to point out one
positional point in this structure you
might be thinking okay I move like c4
humiliates the bishop and he's going to
retreat he's going to go somewhere but
if he doesn't have to go anywhere and he
doesn't this is actually a strategical
mistake by black to lock down the Queen
side you your advantage i mean if you
advantage for white is i got space in
the center and on the kingside and your
advantage is you got the Queen side so
maintaining the pressure there and just
building on it with a move like Knight
to c6 is advised because white always
has to worry about you taking on d4
opening the center getting counter play
and you know that can end a certain
attacks if you have to give away the
center so this actually is it's not very
strategically desirable at such an early
stage it's something you might do later
on when you know you're you're breaking
through on the Queen side or something
but here okay you don't want to move the
bishop back but you have this move which
I mean basically forces you to put a
knight here and now I can take it
but well we'll look at a the main line
here so we won't spend any more time on
the move c4 instead this move and here
sorry after this little threat you have
to do something here as black and you
you really don't want to make any pawn
moves there's a lot of concessions you
don't want to make I mean weakening your
dark squares is disastrous in this line
I think the Queen actually should go to
g4 first but it's the same sorts of
ideas in the future that that might
happen with the knight McQueen coming in
it can be very dangerous h6 can I mean
immediately be met with moves like this
which should be winning for white I
think I mean I think it just wins but I
mean so basically you have to defend
with a piece so Knight to g6 and it was
this position that's been reached 1,500
times or so and there's basically only
one move a move that's 40 times more
popular than what Cara want to play it
in this position so you know it's like
it's a position that everybody has has
just always played Knight to f3 like in
the dab there's like no other moves
nobody's ever done anything but now here
comes Cara wanna US championship and he
comes up with this this move which is
really off the radar you know it looks a
bit strange you know is it's 2,800
player just blundering away the center
you know what could be the point of this
be well I suspect based off this game
that we're going to start seeing this
move a lot more in this position because
okay what the top players are doing is
is quite theoretically important but
let's just take a quick look at the main
line because this is what everybody has
just always played and okay we go here
we understand that whenever we play this
move we're going to take with our F pawn
so now we can understand kind of why the
Queen is here this is the sort of thing
that happens we back up now white is you
know thinking about doing this so we go
somewhere where we're protecting our G
pawn and one defensive resource that
black is going
half in these positions is you kind of
wants to meet h4 with h6 so we need to
make sure that this pawn is actually
well protected and the point is that I
want to be able to meet h5 with g5 so
okay you can attack my queen but I'll
stay where I'm protecting my jeep on and
then I'll kick you away and you're going
to f4 so I'll go here just make sure
this guy is nice and well supported and
okay we go back because now we've got to
do something else so like g4 is coming
so this is the main line which is going
to be very similar to the game so we'll
just look at that because in the game
this move Knight to h3 so I don't know
if that was in Sam's prep I mean he's a
very well-prepared player these kind of
the Battle of like the two most prepared
chess players in the world
they're both known for coming in with
fantastic preparations so here he played
correctly Queen to c7 and now Bishop to
e3 sorry
protecting the center and now after this
you end up taking the night and we know
which way Sam's going to take back and
Queen to g4 and so he's hoping with this
move that it's a slight improvement over
the main line because now we get to do
this a little bit faster so yeah the
typical moves in comes the night and the
night goes back so now that this is
protected enough we can mate h4 with h6
okay so a very interesting game he does
end up going back the point is I want to
play g4 and what's really cool about
this game is white played really really
slow and patient from here out so I mean
he just he just slowly slowly slowly
improved his position and black just sat
there and did nothing so you know it's a
relatively longer game so we're gonna go
kind of quick through it but uh I mean
just what the way he played was just
fantastic it just gave black nothing you
know I'm slightly better in the center
around the kingside I'm just going to
slowly slowly slowly improve and
probably because he knows Danny Machuca
he played f3 and King f2
you know Danny Machuca style and yeah he
actually he's just his idea it's just to
run the King over to g3 the king can
help protect the night the pressure of
the F file is semi annoying you know we
got to do something so alright bring the
King up to g3 and that's exactly what
happened you just brought the king up to
g3 that's step one and ok
you know so sometimes we do want to get
this Bishop on on this diagonal here
sometimes we want to get the bishop to
this diagonal here that's the ultimate
dream but uh you know if you're going to
go here and take this and I have to be
able to take back with a bishop I need
my queen to be defending the knight so
he goes here he's going to play Queen
III just lots of little moves tidying up
the position and it's kind of funny too
because black is breaking it on the
Queen side but it's actually gonna be
white that's going to switch all of his
pieces and he's going to switch all of
his pieces to the coin side so after
this yeah I mean I'm winning in the
center of the Kings side and now I'll
just go win on the Queen side and I'll
own the whole board hey I hate when I
play twenty eight hundreds and they just
win everywhere here there's no
sacrifices you might think about here
because it looks semi interesting but
it's actually nothing the exchange stack
is irrelevant okay you're attacking the
knight now you can even play a move like
this but it doesn't matter I'll just go
here and collect the whole Queen side so
while it's interesting it shouldn't
actually work any of this so he played
Knight to c6
okay the Queen went to e3
now the knight was nice and protected
plenty of times
she's also protecting f3 so it's not
like this is ever going to be a threat
and he went here and a very interesting
thing happened so now this diagonal is
wide open
which when you play these positions you
need to know this manoeuvre for white
that happens all the time okay I'll just
bring my bishop into play
very good you still don't really want to
take I'll trade rooks and all eventually
when you're seep on so he connected his
rooks and okay we attack your rook all
right he took all right I better go get
that C pawn you have to move your rook
and I just take care and very slowly
he's just going to start winning on this
side of the board you pinned me no big
deal and you'll see also black just does
nothing nothing nothing he like he's run
out of things to do and white is going
to keep making very very slow progress
and it's it's really great to watch okay
you get to trade one of the rooks but
the rest of my pieces all of them are
going to go over to the Queen side okay
and he moves back and forth so in comes
the Queen you know it blacks just moves
back and forth alright in comes the
Queen and comes the rook yeah it's just
not a lot of fun he's got to find a way
to get his other pieces over there
black does nothing here a little little
trick all right so he's a tacking the
night the night went back and I wonder
does anybody want to take this pun he
didn't take it but would but should he
have she actually can take it he was he
was just testing so they repeated you
actually can take this but you know you
are allowing some certain things that
happen here so for example black can
play this move looks good I'm going to
take your night and I'm going to take
your Bishop so you sort of have to play
this move it's forced but now the black
queen will get in and after you retreat
I thought Julian pearl Aiko who's back
from China was going to come to this
lecture so I put his favorite symbol on
the board but he's not here to see it
you guys can't see it at home but you
know I got the two arrows which is a
chess based symbol for a with counter
play and I asked everybody I like the
front desk nobody know what that symbol
meant like was that mean but it was for
you Julian and you didn't even come to
come to witness the symbol I gave it for
you so this actually is possible in
computers like yeah the Queen comes in
here no big deal because I'm a computer
and I don't let you perpetual me but
there's no reason you can just keep
sitting here on this position and it's
still good for him all day he's not
gonna let you have any counter play at
all so he was joking you can bring your
knight back I was a joke just testin
just seeing and now he finds something
else to do and it's really funny what he
did with this King here and at the time
like all the commentators nobody knew
like what this was all about but uh he
triangulates for some reason that only
at 2,800 can understand and all the
grandmasters that were here like was he
doing what could that possibly mean and
nobody knows um but okay you know you
got triangulate there for whatever
reason okay all right and he goes back
and the knight is going to begin its its
adventure to way over here
it's yes I guess I guess it is move this
they get him to move 40 so it could be
time control but I'm trying to remember
cuz all commentators are like what kind
of genius the most masterful
triangulation but yeah perhaps he was
just trying to make time control it I
don't remember what it was at the time
and he plays here and he's just going to
shut down the entire kingside and you
pretty much have to play h5 because if
you let me take this and you have to go
here you're giving away a square that's
very easy for me to get to so so this
happened to now the night goes on a
little journey here he goes going on a
little journey and then somewhere around
here a mistake was made in this position
so this is the only blemish on a
otherwise perfect game black actually
had a chance to you know get one of
these symbols he could have in this
position played the remarkable move
Queen to f7 which is very surprising but
if you take here the computer goes here
and it actually finds the perpetual so
yeah this actually doesn't work out so
he would have had to have in this
position traded Queens which he didn't
want to because you know your queen is a
lot better than the black queen in this
position so if here he would take and
he's still better here but you know now
you got to win this position you saw
this game you saw the ending but yeah
I'm yet but he played here and it's just
totally lost this also was funny some
semi triangulated move he went here to a
light square but I was just a joke I
want to be on a dark square you know cuz
yeah you'll never check me but okay this
isn't the greatest piece I've ever seen
in the world and blacks still doing
nothing and okay eventually white he's
slowly slowly slowly coming in I just
wait until everybody is all set and here
black had one last little cheapo these
your very last chance here the night
went here
uh you know blundering a night well he
didn't take it if you go here this is
the easy one to calculate hopefully take
them out but if here rook b8 and then
yeah any Queen moves and we're taking
the knight so you didn't fall for that
he went here and I'll take your knight
on the next move and win lots of
material so here Sam gave it up but it's
just a phenomenal game and it's the kind
of game that you know kind of makes you
worried to play this as black because
it's like they just sit on you the whole
game and I'm winning here I'm winning
the air I'm winning everywhere and just
a very very slow squeeze just complete
torture no fun at all to be black you
know most of us aren't playing 2800 s in
every tournament but you know that was
just a very excellent example and that
the new move Knight to h3 I expect just
to become a lot more popular because
it's on the radar now people know about
it so very very good game and they'll
have to conclude it for this first week
here we will come back with the poison
pond next week so until then hit like
share subscribe and I'll see you guys
next week